i
[Música]
ah
si le alcanzan hito en su campaña de
vacunación al superar los 5 millones de
personas vacunadas con una primera dosis
en su mayoría de la vacuna china sinovac
aunque también se está vacunando con
fisher en total son aproximadamente un
27% de los chilenos los que ya han
recibido una primera dosis mientras que
más de 2.200.000 personas ya han
recibido las dos dosis de la vacuna esto
es aproximadamente un 12% de la
población que ya está vacunada de forma
total esto supone que el gobierno logra
así su objetivo de vacunar a los 5
millones de personas más vulnerables al
cobit antes de finales de marzo con 15
días de antelación y lo sitúa en un muy
buen camino para lograr el objetivo de
vacunar a 15 de los 19 millones de
chilenos antes de finales de junio chile
se sitúa así como el líder de vacunación
en américa latina' muy por delante de
otros países como argentina brasil o
méxico y también entre los 5 países del
mundo que han vacunado a un mejor ritmo
la campaña de vacunación continúa la
próxima semana va curando a personas
sanas en un rango de edad de 59 a 50
años
[Música]
en argentina ya hay más de 2 millones de
personas vacunadas contra el coronavirus
la mayoría ha recibido la primera dosis
pero y cerca de medio millón que también
han sido inoculadas con la segunda en el
país alrededor de 4,5 por ciento de la
población ha recibido al menos una dosis
de acuerdo con el sitio web donde ya es
un nivel similar al de brasil pero está
muy por detrás del ritmo de algunos
países centrales o de chile- la nación
que más rápido está vacunando a su
población en américa latina y que ya ha
dado al menos una dosis a más de un
cuarto de sus habitantes más allá de la
cantidad de vacunas aplicadas argentinas
está cerca de los 4 millones de dosis
distribuidas desde fines de diciembre de
2020 en todo el país pero sigue
esperando que llegue el grueso de las
vacunas comprometidas tras haber firmado
contratos por más de 50 millones de
dosis con diferentes proveedores esta
lentitud de la llegada de las vacunas se
da además en un contexto de alto riesgo
en el que los expertos estiman que se
está cerca de una segunda ola de kobe 19
en el país
[Música]
según epidemiólogos uruguay se encuentra
en rojo en cuanto a la transmisión de
coronavirus y algunas zonas del país
están al borde del colapso sanitario 6
de cada 100 uruguayos se vacunaron
estaban habilitados aquellos en primera
línea de posibilidad de contagio sin
embargo en algunos sectores habilitados
no decidieron hacerlo más del 50 por
ciento de ellos por lo cual una
capacidad ociosa de vacunación y se
abrió para todas las personas entre 50 y
70 años de edad el presidente luis
lacalle pou anunció la llegada de más de
un millón y medio de dosis del
laboratorio sinovac más de 50.000 de
facer y unas doscientas mil de
astrazéneca bajo el mecanismo kóvacs de
la organización mundial de la salud se
habilitará durante la semana de turismo
o semana santa como se llama aquí en
uruguay a todas las personas entre 18 y
70 años el presidente instó a que vayan
a vacunarse
[Música]